hello and welcome to the shaky science
show in this video we'll look at
variability in human aging and genetic
parents so not my catchiest title but it
is what I like to think is quite a
catchy topic right now and so the aim of
this video is to introduce you to why
this variability in human aging and how
genetic variance our cue to us
understanding the biochemical
underpinnings of Asian basically I'm
trying to review this research a few
paper that came out in nature but before
we dive straight in
what is aging well so one definition is
that it is the progressive deterioration
of an organism over time the problem is
aging is complex and takes a long time
to study a lifetime in fact no kleiss I
stole that that pun but anyway I've done
a video before on the different
hallmarks of what actually underpins the
aging mechanism and so I'll put the link
to that video in the description but in
this video we really want to address
what causes the differences between
different people in terms of their aging
raids and given that on the whole the
population is somewhat aging and there's
a huge burden on healthcare costs is
important that we can understand what's
actually driving these aging mechanisms
and how we can actually prevent them so
why does this variation in human aging
come from so variation comes from both
different genetic variants and also from
environmental factors but in this video
we're going to look at the genetic
variance so how can you actually study
genetic variance unfold in aging well
you can do genome-wide Association
studies now I've already done an entire
idea about genome-wide Association
studies what they are in that prison
clones but to briefly summarize they are
studies well by you can take a phenotype
in this case of the aging and look at
genetic variants that are associated
with that phenotype but some like
genome-wide Association studies for
conditions such as Alzheimer's disease
where it's more you I ever have the
condition we don't how do you actually
do genome-wide Association studies or
the complex trait that is aging and how
do you ascertain the extent
to which someone's aging now from what
I've understood there have been two main
ways of doing this so far there's either
a discrete way or a continuous way so
the discrete way to do a genome-wide
Association study for aging is to
directly compare the genomes of people
who are long-lived
I like they live longer than 90 years of
age to younger control individuals
whereas the continuous method methods
whereby he treats the age with the
longevity in this case as a continuous
trait and you measure indirectly the
sense of the aging phenotype by using
parental age so either
the age of the parents whose genome
you're studying or the age of their
deaths now I hope that made sense
so this recent study used the continuous
methods to look for genetic variants
associated with aging and they
identified 12 different DNA regions that
seem to affect lifespan and if you go to
this podcast page you can listen to the
authors explain about their research
which I've been doing but even though
they found these 12 different variants
and I'll talk about a couple of them
later on there's so limitations to this
approach in terms of understanding human
aging the main one being in this
continuous approach that the imperfect
sharing of genotype between a parent and
the child dilutes the strength of these
statistical associations that are needed
to perform genome-wide Association
studies nonetheless many of these ladies
I identified have got Linfen
associations with cardio metabolic
conditions which kind of links back to
the hallmarks of aging but as I said
I'll go into more detail in just a bit
so how else can you analyze the genetic
variation linked to aging now what you
can do as described in this nature of
few people is look at shared genetic
effects on different age associated
diseases so what I mean by this is that
different age associated diseases such
as Alzheimer's disease chronic kidney
disease coronary artery disease
osteoarthritis
stroke type 2 diabetes
and also with two different cancer types
which process the prostate and breast
cancer and colorectal cancer three and
and these diseases or cancers where
they've already been genome-wide
Association studies you can then look at
the variants that were identified in
those studies and look at traits where
the same low sites been associated in
with more than three of these different
diseases and so this assumption can be
made because there is a close
association between the disease and
mortality risk dynamics they based in to
the exponential in terms of the
likelihood of either death or getting
diseases so if we go back to this figure
we can see that coronary artery disease
osteoarthritis type 2 diabetes and
Stroke correlates negatively with
parental longevity but there isn't so
much of an association between prostate
cancer and breast cancer so in Ferentz
associated with different age associated
caesars are not necessarily important
for all different ages associated
diseases but from doing this analysis
nine different genetic ways I have been
identified as hot spots okay so here are
the different loci the first one which
is CAS c8 which stands for cancer
susceptibility clans date eight I'm
actually includes a long non-coding RNA
and is linked with breast prostate and
colorectal cancer the second one is
cdkn2a TB or two as1 so this low sigh
encodes to both different genes and two
of them include p 16 and p 21 which are
both tightly linked with cellular
senescence which as i mentioned in a
previous video is a hallmark of aging
and interestingly the two as1 is another
long non-coding RNA and so this kind of
raises the starts to raise the point
that some of these variants aren't
mutations necessarily in the genes
themselves but are more about regulating
the expression of these different genes
instead so the third one is tcf7l2 which
is links to betta cell proliferation and
insulin response and again it's got
links with cancer and type 2 diabetes
then mostly HLA DQ a1 blue side which is
including the histocompatibility complex
components and that's linked with
chronic information again something
that's associated with the hallmarks of
aging then v lo site is [ __ ] which is the
low side that encodes the different
antigens that kind of to take your blood
group and say so far one of the antigen
seems to be the ferrant associated most
of longevity unfortunately it's not my
blood type then we have sh t b3 which
encodes the lymphocytes adapter protein
and is linked with inflammation and
immune response so interestingly this
isn't the sh t b1 or b2 gene which is
linked with igf-1 signaling which is
actually also linked to aging but that
isn't the fairing that was found here
then we have veg F a FTO and they are
both also linked with information in the
immune response FTO I've talked about
again a previous video it's linked with
obesity and also well the there's a lot
but isn't really fully known about this
gene yeah it's it's very interesting
gene I know lastly we have tart which in
case telomerase which extends telomers
again which is a hallmark of telomere
shortening as a hallmark of aging which
i've explained before
so if you are interested in
understanding 37 hallmarks of Hanna do
recommend well what other things do my
video but just looking at reading the
literature around the hallmarks region
anyhow back to this list of lace I you
may notice that that some loose I are
missing which you might have thought
should be there so one of these is a p/e
in particular the apoe4 variants which
is one of the most significant variants
associated with outside necessity
and again because of a sink without
sinus disease and also cardiometabolic
diseases is one of the most significant
lows I associated with parental lifespan
it just wasn't picked up by looking at
the shared traits across different
diseases
another variant that also was in the
list was Fox a3 a which includes focus a
Fourier that should say Forsyth clear I
said now as I said for 3a too many times
and anyway this inque is a transcription
factor that influences energy metabolism
cell cycle regulation and information
and so it's very tightly linked to the
hallmarks of aging but you know the
ferrant seems so far I've only seen been
seen in the longest-lived 1% of people
so it seems that generically and on a
population scale the ferrant doesn't
really seem to have a major impact in
lifespan but again due to the
limitations of genome-wide Association
studies it could be a variant that could
become noticed when a larger population
of people are sequence and traits that
looks out for what studies like this
show is that there is a genetic
component to aging and lifespan and the
fact is studies and different organisms
so for example one model organism C
elegans they've done a study why they
had genetically identical C elegans and
even then they died at differen
different times despite also having very
similar the same environmental
conditions and so this also suggests
that the variability is somewhat
spontaneous and aging itself is a
spontaneous process and so this added
complexity just makes aging by itself
really difficult to study but it's also
wise to say interesting so it seems
besides genetics and lifestyle factors
it's bit of a role for guide for the
dice in terms of how long the rings live
or age and you know we can't all be like
mr. burns he seems to have every single
to see as possible but because they're
in perfect balance he doesn't suffer for
many of them we're not like that
um the likelihood is there's many
different age satiated diseases but if
we can actually
look at the genetic variance I'll
identify the genes associated it enables
us to better understand the aging
Methodism and therefore develop drugs
and targets for those drugs which could
help to prevent or slow down the process
of aging itself so hopefully you found
this video interesting if you want to
see more videos go check out this one
but I found my fitness it's really
recently in tube of David Sinclair he's
sorry I knew on its and the aging field
and again check out my other videos or
about the hallmarks of aging yes thanks
for listening and see you next time